Bueno al gobierno de Dina boluarte le
queda la única salida de insistir con el
proyecto que ha presentado el Primer
Ministro Alberto tarola al parlamento
peruano precisamente la comisión de
Constitución ha citado al Primer
Ministro peruano a que acuda el día que
ha sido citado que va a ser dentro de
unas horas se va a abrir este caso en la
comisión del congreso para que el Primer
Ministro detalle Cuál es el alcance en
sí de la iniciativa pero muchos
analistas están diciendo que eso va a
ser un alargue porque la comisión de
Constitución va a tener luego que
debatir la aprobarla y enviarla a la
comisión permanente esta Va a ser el
mismo proceso para enviarla al pleno del
parlamento peruano y someter la votación
muchos están vaticinando que el
parlamento no va a aprobar esto y al
gobierno de boluarte le va a quedar
enviar al Primer Ministro a hacer
cuestión de confianza para que se
apruebe la reforma